see on starting immediately my right
here we said now if you order of my
sheet so give me a second here we have a
Tyler Thorson he is the main man in
editorial creative and customer
experience that guilt to Tyler's right
we have Jeff Rader of Harry Harry's
Warby Parker you name it he co-founded
it and then we have Andy Spade he's the
co-founder of Jack Spade Kate Spade and
partners and spade a storefront and
studio producing content as well as
serving as an agency for top brands then
to his right we have Michael praise Minh
the founder and CEO of eberlein
providing transparency and great design
and well-priced direct-to-consumer
apparel and finally we have Emmett shine
founded Gin Lane media a digital
creative agency working with content
creators and brands such as Jay Crew
opening ceremony and Stella McCartney
so I want to start with a sort of a
top-line question kind of about why
we're here in the first place
coming from Forbes I have to represent
the viewpoint of capitalism at all times
and one of the the foundational tenets
of capitalism is this specialization of
Labor the idea that you should do the
thing that you're best at and then pay
someone else to do the thing that you're
not best at but we're here to talk about
this idea that content and commerce are
chocolate and peanut butter there there
everybody is suddenly saying that
they're better done together than in a
park why is that the thinking now why is
that what everybody's where everybody
seems to think the money is anybody
happy to hear from any of you on this
but Tyler since you've worked both sides
of the divide I especially interested
and since I promised I wouldn't start
with you okay that agreement we made off
before we started um well I think let's
be honest part of it's just that second
revenue stream that ad-supported media
or third or whatever if you've got you
know ads and you've got subscriptions
then retail and e-commerce isn't is an
attractive revenue stream to look at and
I also think the internet and e-commerce
has just open up opportunities both for
for publishers to add you know an
e-commerce element but also of course
for folks like us at gilt - to publish
content we really look at it you know we
it's all about defining your goal with
us it guilt is it you know it's less for
us about driving inbound traffic and and
sort of growing our member base it's up
to I think eight million now and it's
more about conversion and sort of
inspiring our guy to kind of try new
things so that's the way we look at it
on our side we do you know I think from
from serve in terms of like where you
want to approach this if you want to be
successful in this space trend and
bringing content into a commerce
perspective you really have to you know
narrow your goals and really focus on
you know sort of define your goals
clearly and I think for us what we found
is is focusing on conversion and in a
real technical way so I get more into
that but I want to hear more from these
guys
oh I didn't I can respond I think it's
always been that way I mean I would say
if you look at you know editorial you
know over the years you know they've
always helped sell product they weren't
making revenue off it but they were you
know helping others make revenue the
same in television and in film product
placement has a existence for many many
years and and we've always known on the
on the commerce side that you know the
great way to sell your product is to get
it editorialized right or to get it into
a movie or on television what's happened
lately though is that with technology
and I've got a surprise that more
magazines and and television production
companies haven't started their own
their own retail divisions or commerce
divisions I saw a show called the shed
on reality TV the other day and I
honestly thought it was made up by the
producers to sell merchandise from the
shed and I thought what I'm doing an
idea I'm gonna create a show about this
restaurant like love a shrimp and I'm
gonna make it up and then I'm gonna sell
t-shirts online and tons of press
there's a big business in it so I think
it's just evolved I think with what
these two guys are doing is sort of
they're starting by developing a product
they believe in you know both 'never
Lane and Harry's and sort of then saying
all right
how do we make this relevant how do we
tell that story and I think that's
really you know the key for us is like
when you when you talk about whether or
not they created that show like to
actually you know sell things or like
let's buy all this stuff of let's create
a show to sell it I mean that's
essentially you know what we're doing
people talk a lot about credibility then
right it's like well how do you trust
you know what what you guys are saying
you know and I feel like well you know
we bought it like we invested in this
stuff you know and I feel like that's an
argument that Jeremy Langmead the
editor-in-chief mr. Porter made I think
was like in the business of fashion or
something that was really impressive
like you know in a magazine context
there's a lot of reasons you choose one
thing or another you know in in retail
like we're actually positioning
something or whether it's ever laying or
Harry's like we're actually saying hey
we believe in this stuff we invested in
it nine months ago you know we're
invested in shooting it now we're gonna
tell you how to wear it we're gonna make
it really attractive to you and we're
hopefully gonna do it in a way that's
kind of cool and engaging
and make it look fun and so I feel like
from that perspective you know the idea
of like can I trust your judgment can I
trust the advice you're giving like I
think the proof is in the pudding the
faculty we just kind of went and bought
this product so you know that's kind of
covered which is cool so that raises a
good question
in this convergence it seems like the
maybe for retailers that the path is a
little shorter and smoother to to
content than it is in the other
direction that for content producers for
publishers that that they're making this
transition is this reinvention of
themselves more out of necessity than
out of kind of an opportunity that you
know big fat dangling opportunity in
front of them is that is anybody uh have
a take on that is it easy for retailers
well I just think that I think it is
easier in that kind of way the way that
you run a retail business the way that
you manufacture than that process I'm
not saying it's easier than doing
editorial I've done both on several
occasions it's just a whole different
skill set and it's a different team and
they both are but you know monocle has
tried to do this for a while I don't
think that it will ever be big I think
it's a really brilliant idea to do it
but I mean you really have to you know
support it you have to have equal
attention we just launched a brand out
of our advertising studio called sleepy
Jones but we are developing a huge team
that represents half of the staff of our
of our agency slash you know branding
studio and you really have to dedicate
time to it I've seen a lot of people on
the on the content side trying to launch
you know commerce and vice versa but I
don't know if anyone else has any ideas
about this I just think your skill sets
are different I think it's um I think
for our brand it's sometimes just very
natural to develop compelling content
because it's Tyler's point we invested
it ourselves we believe it and we want
to tell that story that customers and it
really helps the deepen the relationship
that we have with customers from the
moment that they interact with the brand
sort of through their
their journey on the content side agree
with Andy I think it's really important
to invest and I think vice versa I think
lots of brands and companies get in
trouble when they or just don't do
things that are compelling when they
just kind of go halfway
tons of brands have launched blogs and
it's like yeah I've got a blog it's cool
there's a bunch of content but it's not
necessarily as thoughtful as as the rest
of the brand and so I think it's really
important when you develop content just
to be very clear about what the content
is how it reinforces the brand message
and then to really deeply invest behind
it so how do you know if you're doing if
the content you're doing is good and
what's your is your measuring stick
conversion or if your if your user
I mean conversion into sales or if your
if your consumers are enjoying it but
it's not necessarily inspiring and reach
for their wallets is it good content I
think that's a really good question
interested in some other folks opinions
by the way that we think about it at
Harry's and that Warby Parker is there
are some things that are highly
measurable and by running a business
where we sell the majority of our
product online you can measure results
incredibly quickly we can serve two
images and see which image people
respond better to very quickly I think
though that there are things that we do
that are sometimes just because we have
a vision around them for the brand and
we think that they are gonna help us to
further define the brand and those are
very hard things to to sort of quantify
and lots of times we just talk about
building a brand that's bigger than the
business and one that's gonna last for a
long time and sometimes in those
instances you have to have a vision for
that brand a long-term vision and just
make decisions to develop you know
content for the brand or do things make
strategic choices for the brand that may
not manifest themselves and immediate
results I do think it's true that you
have a vision I would say that even when
you do though you can still measure
pretty well so we do let's say our brain
is about transparency and we'll push out
content around infographics around the
cost and we'll push out other types of
stories and you can just generally tell
when people engage with the content as
you see more traffic to the site you see
people talking about it on social media
and then you sort of guide your
a bit more towards that type of content
so you'll have an initial I think the
way that we think about it internally is
we have an initial vision and then we
use some level of data or engagement to
guide us in the right direction over
time and that's just an iterative
process over and over and over again
completely and I think that that makes
it that make sense around focus but
probably also always want to have a
cohesive brand story for sure so there
may be some elements that people aren't
engaging with but it helps you tell that
story that's totally and I think there's
one other point when we were launching
our first first brand Kate we talked
about you know being a handbag company
but we knew in the back of our minds
that we were creating a world that would
give us permission to go into other
categories we weren't just a handbag
company and we're always talked about
brands like ferla and furloughs
advertising was always a photograph of a
ferla bag and ferla has you have to have
a fragrance a deal and I think there's a
reason for it we created an entire world
around our brand and we told our story
it was about this person and how they
lived and what they liked and before we
had e-commerce we would tell that story
in our retail environment too we had a
little second said things Kate likes and
so we started just having a dialogue and
relationship with customers what kind of
car we like what kind of cocktail we
like what kind of you know house we live
in all these different things and I
think with like Warby and Harry's is the
customer has to see that we did get
direct you know invested back from that
but over time they allowed us to go into
shoes they allowed us to go into hats
they allowed us to go into fragrance
they allowed us to go into home and all
those little cues that we kind of put
forth to the consumer kind of educated
consumer and made them understand that
we were actually bigger than just a
handbag from a brand level at sort of a
cohesive story across the entire product
set from men to women and you're
building a lifestyle for you know
basically at the end of the day what are
your values and what do you believe in
and then people sort of attribute
themselves to those values and say hey
that's the life I want to live and then
you know there's a story behind the
product that they buy into you wanted
the coke sorry sorry I mean yeah yeah I
think a common thread
texts and I think that's like another
see I'll try to speak into this that's
important in terms of what we're really
kind of talking about and the brands and
and the work that these guys do is as
you were giving an analogy with Kate
Spade stuff you contextualized kind of
more the ethos of what it was about
which makes it easier to get into
another vertical or whatever it's it's
about narratives it's its storytelling
and I think the the content really
baguettes that it helps that it makes it
so that it's easier for someone to
contextually understand what they're
looking at what a brand's about and what
they can do versus like here's a
mannequin and here's a shirt on a
mannequin there's no context you know
and that's I guess a similar word kind
of for like the content that's being
created contextualizes what the brand is
about and what the experience is so I
think if you're working on a brand or
you're working with the brand you want
to really understand the root of what
that brand is about or you know so you
can give the kind of narrative or the
context I think that that dialogue is
really important and on the context I
mean I think a brilliant example is what
partners into paid guys did with sleepy
Jones and the manifesto that they wrote
about just wanting to wake up and lounge
in your PJs all day and it just sort of
gave a product that was otherwise a
fairly I'd always thought have a fairly
basic product some meaning I was like
cool these are my my boxers that I'm
just gonna hang out in like on a
Saturday for a few hours and I think
that actually like it just created a
life silent experience around a product
that either wise maybe wouldn't have
imagined so and I think I think to that
point when we launched and we just
launched about four months ago sleepy
Jones we thought about categories I had
worked in accessories for so many years
and I saw this category that's been
around for you know obviously hundreds
of years you know you think about men's
boxers women's underwear I would say is
that the way to pronounce it and pajamas
allowed where and that lifestyle right
now everyone's so busy everyone's
working so hard I detectives so we just
did the t-shirt that just says [ __ ] tech
and the idea is that you know
sit back ponder stare at the ceiling you
know keep a notebook by your by your bed
make notes the best ideas come in your
when you're comfortable not in
three-piece suits how many brilliant
ideas of I'm sure a lot have actually
but I think we were looking for it for a
point of view and then obviously the
products most important but we wanted to
have a point of view about what's going
on in society and culturally what people
are feeling right now and have them
identify with something that we believe
it's something we believe in I gotta say
it's like fun listening to you guys
because you're all individual brands or
so to speak or the partners in Spade hat
or gin Lane like you're generally
working with like a single vertical
brand and like you know we're a multi
brand retailer and that's like a you
know I see Eric you know from sac city I
mean that's a totally different
situation where you're bringing together
all these other brands and you're trying
to layer what your brand means on top of
that and you know when I look at at
Harry's or Warby or eberlein and like
what you guys have been able to do to
tell the story of your product and build
your brand it's like oh yeah that's
awesome I could totally do that now how
do we can't do that with the hundreds
and hundreds or thousands of brands that
we work with so you know it's a it's a
different proposition but the ideal I
think for a retailer is if you know the
fact that you Brooke bought that product
from that retail adds some value to it
somehow like it makes it that much
cooler that I bought it here
you know and I think that's kind of that
magic that that you know that you're
trying to cultivate on a completely
unrelated note I got a say coming from
you know a click based ad based
situation and moving into gilt and I've
been at gilt for like a little over
three years now man I have a newfound
respect for the difference between
getting somebody to click on something
and getting somebody to buy something
because let me tell you it's a little
easier to get somebody to click on
something and get those impressions up
than it is to actually get somebody to
buy something so what's the secret what
takes place in between those two moments
well I think you do
you can track both and you can certainly
track you know conversion and sales and
it's really important to do that but I
think too
you content and what I like to say is I
look at it more like an editorial
approach it's not just about content
being this sort of you know a lot of
people look at as is some fairy dust
we're just gonna sprinkle and this real
kind of corporate mindset like oh we got
a budget for content let's just Chuck a
little content over there that'll help
that so it's either that or you know or
it just becomes this commodity it's like
I don't know can you get some guy to do
some content in there
what's we're gonna put in this space you
know when you look at a wireframes like
oh this is where the content goes oh
that's yeah that's gonna work yeah we
have to populate these modules yeah okay
that's maybe not the right approach so
what is the secret I mean I think it's
you know starting from the proposition
that like selling something isn't an
inherently inauthentic experience like
you can actually you know people think
just you're selling something that
there's some up pulling one over on
somebody like I know you can do that in
a very straight ahead honest way and so
in a way it's more authentic than some
of the some of the transactions that
take place in a pure play content
environment yeah it could could be your
inner motives are on the table for sure
for sure a while you know that jinlun
guys shared with our team at Harry's
this was in the context of building our
site at Harry's and trying to tell our
brand story and create content around
the brand that would help people to
understand the brand and then hopefully
eventually want to buy the product this
this article that was written about the
fact that ecommerce was kind of bringing
people back to an old-school store
experience where you'd walk in to got
you know a store where someone sold a
bar of soap and the guy would know your
name and he'd know what soap was right
for you and you can have an honest
conversation with him about a set of
products he'd help you make an
intelligent choice and then you'd walk
out and I think in some ways if you are
effective in ecommerce you're able to
get to know people tell them really
compelling brand stories follow up with
them personally so Harry's for instance
we we email all of our customers after
they buy and just say hey we're here for
you we love you we want to get to know
you and help you make good choices and
in doing that you can build a trusting
relationship with them which then in
turn just makes them feel more
comfortable buying product from you now
I think the next level of
of complexity there and I think there's
something that Michael aberlin team have
done an amazing job of is figuring out
how to sort of position that content in
the right way on a website - or you're
in sort of a purchase flow to get
someone to do it and in the optimal
fashion you know like where do I put
this to catch your eyes such that you
can you you want to read the story and
understand it but I think that's
fundamentally what what everyone is
really going for which is it's to make
the to use it to make the experience
feel authentic not yeah um and you had
something to say but I'm but I'm
interested in hearing more about that I
can say you please okay please thank you
I think when I first started I started
advertising but I I moved to New York in
1987 and I discovered Paul Smith and all
of you I'm sure know Paul Smith and he
was the one who really taught me about
content and and in a retail environment
at the Talia's point you know he sold
Japanese robots you know he sold books
by you know unknown authors unknown
photographers he sold you know old
typewriters you know vintage cameras you
know Japanese ephemera and everything
was for sale he's very honest it
actually contextualized his brand I
would go in constantly to see what he
was interested in personally I can't
even fit into the clothing I don't think
I own any of the clothing maybe a pair
of shoes but I would visit that store
every week to see what he had discovered
in his travels and and that taught me
that you know when we moved into this
space we're online were putting content
in it's really he had a specific voice I
liked what he liked identified with
whatever he was curious you know about
but you're right like it doesn't have to
be content for content sake you can sell
it and that's honest
and you know great retailers know that
now is we know what's happened is the
reverse in the beginning we start our
website and said can it reflect our you
know the really interesting retail
environment that we had in Jack's baton
Kate Spade god that's going to be hard
to do now it's reversed now our partners
I'm trying to figure out how do we make
the retail space as interesting is
what's happening online right now
because there's so many different places
you can go and things you can do and it
moves so quickly it's actually
interesting when you think about a
physical store right you have that
opportunity to build a real space and to
create
world online it's much harder because
you don't have you don't have the walls
you don't have all this space what
people come to an online store they want
to shop and so for us we actually
separate those two experiences out and
so the equivalent of Paul Smith is our
blog it's the social media stuff that
you do and that's where you create the
brand persona people say hey I follow
you because I want to be attached to the
brand and then when they go into
shopping mode we used to try to put some
of that content in there but we pulled
it all out because we found through our
studies that people when they shop they
just want to shop at least online and so
we take all of that out and we only put
product focused content so you get on
the product page and then we try to put
as much content as possible because
that's where people spend all their time
is on the product page and so you have
your world which is social media and
then you have your product focused
content in that shopping mode and that's
what we do is that what you're driving
at with we're in the flow the the
content yeah I think that's right I
think the other thing is that the
product content can sometimes be the
most compelling content because you tell
this product story this you know about
the fact that you a very different model
in retail and that you're you know
sourcing stories are great our content
is easy because it's about our product
so it's like but we don't have any but I
think it reinforces the brand message
it's trust and then so I think sometimes
that that content gets overlooked but
those stories on the product pages I
think are some of the most important
yeah absolutely I mean I think that's
something that editorially magazines
have known for a long time right those
are those pages people just love to flip
through product pages for sure and you
know I think that's you know the key is
that you have to put yourself you know
you come I come from an editorial
background like biasing because I want
to write something I want to package
something up but like if they start from
the premise of like what's the person
coming to the site looking for you know
if I'm looking to buy something I don't
want something in the way you know and
so from from our perspective you know on
gilt man will do a sale we do have a
bunch of front brands if we're doing a
trend sale you know we're doing
something that's going up at noon today
that sort of our fall kind of get the
look series and it's a trend series and
you know it's all about kind of
old-school style and a fresh take and
you know what we like to do in those
situations is we'll
the trend will present the look will
kind of show you hey here's what we
think here's our point of view and we
think that's gonna get you in the door
we think that's gonna get you to click
and get intrigued but then it's about
you know you just you decide like you
take the take the reins from there and I
feel like that's I'm speaking from the
men's experience in particular like we
find that's really compelling like guys
they want to feel like they can own the
the sort of process right they want you
want to give them a sense of like you're
not just leading them by the Nate you
know it's so the idea of like shop the
look you can go too far in that
direction and you need to give guys
options now you look at the site today
in the sale we're doing is the most shop
to look like sale we ever do but
oftentimes that's sort of what we try to
do we say like here's three ways to make
this look your own and we're just gonna
give a bunch of really cool product
beneath it and you you take it from
there so we're gonna get out of the way
I think that that really works for us
so you're saying women like to be led by
the nape exactly I'm saying oh man just
get this down everybody men are but no
I'm not I'm saying that I can only speak
from the men's perspective I do feel
like to this product page discussion
like men like to research their
purchases and sort of circle around
something a little bit more it's either
an impulse which obviously it's guilt
it's fast it's like got to move faster
it's gone but then there's also a lot of
high-end stuff that we sell and I feel
like you know we're hitting you every
day with that email with that mobile
alert like people you know they that
play over to opportunity to interact
with with guilt what we try to do a
little is a little bit of that Paul
Smith kind of attitude a little bit of
that perspective and point of view that
we know that you know you may not be in
the market for a suit right now but
we're top of mine oh when I have when I
need this I'm gonna come to you guys
because I kind of like your general
perspective on things and I think that's
that's what Paul Smith can do when he's
doing all the robots and the curated
books and the ephemera you know his
business is like god I I need a really
cool pair of socks
I'm gonna go to that guy who head with
the robots you know and I feel like
there's something you know there's
something to that it's just you you
can't really track the value that the
tricky part is tracking the value of
that I don't know hug the Mike here I
just but that my boss is like it's it's
amazing because we've worked together
for a year now and he comes from the
annelid
call numbers side and now he calls the
editorial stuff that we do our secret
sauce and you know it's working for us
so I think we've got it down to a you
know a good good place yeah I'll just
add one quick thing that is one big
portion of car one big aspect of content
is to sort of create the story and be
top of mind people with people and we've
seen with ever line people have followed
us for you know 16 months and they say
oh I finally just bought that and so
you're just there you're there you're
there and then finally for some reason
you do one thing and it pulls the
trigger and they go and become a
customer and so that is the other big
aspect of content is just always being
top of mind and just making just being
available for them I'm interested we're
gonna take questions from the audience
in a minute but I'm interested in just
hearing anyone else's thoughts about
what is unique or different about the
way that you know the way that you have
to sort of speak to men in particular
with your your content your your your
commerce driven content or your content
driven commerce I think as you said you
know men don't like being kind of told
what to do to a certain extent I think
they like having the tools kind of
presented and then being able to work
with what's there and make their own
kind of decisions I just wanted to go
back to one point I think with Harry's
and Warby and ever Lane there's a lot of
content which is created in telling the
narratives of the product and that's one
thing we worked a lot on with Harry's is
there's not a lot of SKUs but it's you
know it's it's it's low in the amount
but very high in kind of the narrative
for it so and and ever Lane also there's
a lot of like infographics and
information and like the product
photography in a narrative you have per
say like a longer scroll so I think
again it comes back to where we have the
brick-and-mortar kind of analogy of a
store and stores have been existing for
hundreds and hundreds if not thousands
of years online stores have not so it's
it's very new and people are trying to
figure out how to contextualize the
experience so that you don't go just to
you know a white page and and there's
your skewed off to the you know
mannequin thing with information on the
right I don't know how to do anything
unless I understand what the hell is
going on so when I go to shop online
it's very different than going into
a soho store and you know the smell
there's someone to talk to there's music
playing you know the street there's a
whole ambiance that you buy into it's
not always just the fabric count of why
you get a shirt you're buying into a
lifestyle and Association a narrative
and so when you online if there isn't a
narrative what's what's the point it's
not as you said as clique driven its
it's the customers getting smarter and I
think the two have to play with each
other which is a big conversation that
we're focused on is taking that which
digital offers and putting it into brick
and mortar because there's a lot of
quantifiable intelligence that can go
qualitatively make sense and then the
qualitative of which the brick and
mortar wonderful kind of world
experience offers you can pull in for
web so it's it's contextual and I think
just to not ramble the I think women
like to as they say kind of treasure
hunt you know a little bit of the the
mix and match and and save something
here and put into a card and come back
to look at it later and I think men you
know to stereotype they are more driven
and knowing what they kind of want to
find and then they want the assisting
information from an expert or have the
ability to contextualize how it could
make sense but still feel kind of in
control do you think that
brick-and-mortar retailers or
brick-and-mortar I mean nobody's a brick
and mortar retailer anymore but do you
think brick-and-mortar native retailers
have learned a lot from from digital
native retailers in terms of this need
to contextualize and build some story I
think a good takeaway with like your
quote unquote disruptive techno they or
ever laying it's as they've been
mentioning it's very quantifiable you
really have access to information in
numbers and that's one thing it's like
think of like Google kind of overview
for analytics for a site it's very easy
to see oh well this page got this click
through and this didn't here's my basic
a/b testing it's a little bit more
difficult in your mom-and-pop store to
kind of do that if you know say Joe who
runs a counter is sick for four weeks or
whatever you know and he calls up Tom
and says hey Tom like how are the
metrics looking for the conversions for
walking in you know it's like you know
Tuesday seemed kind of busy so I think
that's an important part that you can
take into brick-and-mortar
is-is-is matching the qualitative of
like you know well joe said he really
liked the sandwich that he made for him
or whatever and then the quantitative of
saying well it looks like you know on
tuesday when it rained that you know
traffic increased you know by twenty
percent and in the back of the store
they are we're really not seeing anyone
touch those pants and then these things
are flying off the shelf for some reason
so you can analyze that information so I
think that's saying that like is is
going into quote-unquote
brick-and-mortar what another just thing
on that I completely agree that the way
that I may contextualize this and we've
talked about this which is our challenge
in a digital world is to make is to
create the ambiance of a store online
and I think one thing that that we spent
a lot of time with Jim Lane talking
about in the context of Harry's was the
fact that web pages are not static and
that there are I think the advantage
that we have in a digital world is the
ability to create dynamic content and
serve it to people an interesting way so
you don't have to just see a story
written on a page like you know our
product pages and Harry's you can spin
our razors and inter actually interact
with them like as you scroll down the
pages different interactive elements
happen they catch your eye and I think
they they help to sort of reinforce the
fact that you were an innovative brand
doing innovative things online and also
just the the digital format is I think
getting more and more compelling around
storytelling than it than it was
previously
minutes and we have any questions out in
the audience and we do right there
either kind of the context or conceptual
thing that I'm noticing here is as a
either an editorial or trying to sell
with any of your content you're just
trying to build trust with whoever it is
so if your partners in Spade and you
come out with a new product
I trust you already so that makes it
easier for me to do that so when your
content matches up with your product
whatever it is which then goes back to
the brick and mortar old score like if I
go into a store down the block for me I
want to trust that that guy's not gonna
rip me off that he's offering the best
product all that stuff you're just
trying to emulate that online the best
way that you absolutely can that's all
come
the only thing I would add to that is we
try to build trust and we try to create
stories that are shareable so even
though we're building trust we want that
story to be interesting enough that
somebody goes and tells my friends so
it's both those at the same time but
that's also again a very you know
thousands of years thing which is
totally regular word-of-mouth yeah I
think he started off saying yeah it
hasn't really changed it's the same as
it was a hundred years ago we have one
right down front hey guys I'm curious to
know how since we're a tech and taste
maker conference how taste makers have
sort of affected businesses today and
how they interact with I guess creating
content and because often you find a lot
of brands reaching out to taste makers
and quote-unquote influencers to sort of
like create these content stories or
these contextual stories for them so I'm
just cruising here from you guys how you
guys kind of separate that I think the
way that we sometimes think about the
best way for someone to learn about our
brand
hairy's or Corby Parker is through a
credible source and that's why we
focused a lot early on on editorial
content because you know publications
like details are credible sources for
lots of people to just learn about brink
brands and people trust what they say
and so when we think about taste makers
or influencers I think what we really
want to do is find people who are
credible in helping us to tell our brand
story and then have them sort of have a
conversation with Costume potential
customers as if they were friends almost
telling that story and I think that goes
back to what Michael said about creating
content that's shareable if the most
credible source that I have for someone
to tell me about a product that's a
friend of mine who's who I trust and so
to the extent that we can sort of create
that relationship between an influencer
and our customers that's great and it's
the side that we can create content
that's shareable among lots of people
then you start to get the brand
introduced through lots different
credible sources and reinforced that way
sometimes it takes two or three
different credible sources to get you
actually buy but I think that's that's
how we've thought about using like that
would I
go ahead in I was just gonna say very
quickly what I love about the digital
space and crowdsourcing is how quickly
it allows people to sniff through the
[ __ ]
it's like Oh Trust is important how do
we co-op that you know let's how do we
engineer trust you know or you know the
old saying about sincerity you know if
you can fake that you got it made so I
just feel like there's that whole notion
of the real guy you know like oh this
guy's live in the lifestyle etc how do
we kind of we're some big corporate
entity how do we tap into that you know
you can only go so far before that
starts to ring a little hollow you know
but we were actually sending sending it
up a little bit I see Stephen Rojas back
there we're kind of one of the one of
the amazing real guys that everyone
wants to photograph right now we're
doing a thing with him and this month
he's mr. September we're kind of
spoofing of that a little bit and this
whole we're creating a whole social
campaign this month about reclaiming
September which I find to be the most
underrated month of the year and I'll
you know go to guilt manual for more on
Rojas over there but uh and some posters
September selfie hashtag September
selfie
well did you have something to add there
no no how could you do better than
September selfies thank you thank you
all very much this was great and
everybody don't forget to get your [ __ ]
tech t-shirt and gift bag on the way out
you